- [Instructor] Let's say that I were
to walk up to you on the street
and said alright, I have
this function g of x,
which I'm going to define
as the definite integral
from 19 to x of the cube root
of t dt.
And then I were to ask
you what is the derivative
of g evaluated at 27?
Pause this video,
and think about how you
would approach that.
Well, the most obvious thing would be
g-prime of x, and I'll switch colors here
just for a little bit of contrast,
g-prime of x is going to be the derivative
with respect to x of all of this business,
of all of, I'll put it in brackets here.
The integral from 19 to x
of the cube root of t dt.
And you might be tempted to
take the antiderivative here
and evaluated it x, evaluated it at 19,
find the difference and
then take the derivative
and you could do that, and
then evaluate that at 27.
But we're going to see a short cut.
You could just use the
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus.
If you're taking the
derivative with respect to x
of a function that's defined
by a definite integral like this
where our upper boundary is x,
this is just going to be
equal to our inner function
right over here, with instead
of t being the variable,
it would now be x.
So this is just going to be
equal to the cube root of x.
And that saved us some time there,
but it can be really
useful if this function
inside the integral is really hard
to take the antiderivative of.
It's really hard to
evaluate this integral.
The Fundamental Theorem of
Calculus can be very useful.
And so going back to
our original question,
g-prime of 27, well this is just going
to be equal to the cube root of 27,
which, of course, is equal
to three, and we're done.